Donald Trump is taking advice from an 85
year old boxing promoter over the
weekend a truly strange story slipped by
some of us and I want to tell you about
it 85 year-old boxing promoter Don King
is allegedly advising Donald Trump Don
King is I guess a longtime friend of
Trump's and was sort of advising him
during the campaign and according to a
political article Don King is still
advising Donald Trump some of Don King's
credentials include having been found
guilty of second-degree murder in 1966
ultimately reduced to manslaughter and
pardoned in 1983 being investigated for
connections to organized crime over
which he ultimately pleaded the fifth
and being accused of having blackmailed
or stolen money from a very long list of
his boxing clients and according to Don
King this is surreal Trump talks to him
about serious issues like for example
the firing of Michael Flynn here's an
excerpt from this interview where
Politico asked what has your what does
Trump ask your advice about and King
responded I've been to mar-a-lago a few
times we sat down for one hour earlier
this year he wanted to get my estimation
of what's going on he said what do you
think about me firing Flynn I said with
all due respect mr. president Flynn
fired himself
Trump's loyal to a fault he'll speak on
your behalf because out on the street
you can stick with a guy and say he did
the wrong thing but he's basically a
good guy
that's not crooked that's not
obstructing justice that's friendship so
a lot of that was hard to understand in
parse but allegedly what Don King is
saying is that the President of the
United States went to an 85 year old
boxing promoter to get his opinion about
the firing of a Russia connected lying
national security adviser can we be too
surprised though this is the reality TV
star president this is a guy who
wrestled on WWE right this is a guy who
appeared in a softcore porno for a
Playboy I mean it's not like it's beyond
him and people will write in and say
David it's a fake story the White House
has not denied it the White House
confirmed to The Daily Beast that
Don King and Trump keep in touch that
they remain quote close friends with
quote deep respect and admiration for
one another and a former Trump campaign
official said that King is one of Donald
Trump's favorite people who Trump loved
talking about throughout the entire
campaign what world are we living in
when a clueless boxing promoter is
talking to the President of the United
States about issues of international
importance are these the best people
that Donald Trump promised to put around
himself it's the the dumb leading the
dumb and also why is king holding a
Russian flag in that photo
no yeah look at that I didn't even
notice this when I selected this picture
the picture we have up that is the
Russian flag right yeah I think he
decked out in American you know apparel
I guess you'd say like the flag of
Statue of Liberty oh and he's holding a
number at least two Russian flags in
this picture I actually I genuinely have
no idea why in this picture Don King is
holding multiple Russian flags but did
we just find the smoking gun in the
Russia's story do we know any I do we
know anything about this I have no idea
I don't know when the pictures from very
very strange okay so anyway Donald Trump
apparently still taking advice from an
85 year old boxing promoter who is
photographed with Trump holding multiple
Russian flags which makes the story
marginal marginally more pathetic it
doesn't it doesn't totally change the
story but it does make it a little bit
weirder